honestly you can't overstate how much a
short-term mindset dominates Westminster
and from there how it infects all the
institutions which try and fail to run
Britain from the center
I call it sticking plaster politics
sticking plaster politics and in a kind
of last minute frenzy it sometimes
delivers relief
but the long-term cure
that always eludes us
and it's at the heart of all the
problems we see across the country right
now
I'll give you an example
energy and the cost of living crisis
now thank heavens we have a price freeze
this winter
that labors campaigning in the summer
eventually brought the government to our
position and its senses
but truth be told the price freeze is
the perfect example of sticking plaster
politics necessary off course
but nonetheless an expensive last minute
fix papering over cracks in our energy
security that have been on display for
years
now don't get me wrong nobody criticizes
the government for the effects of the
war in Ukraine
but the war didn't scrap home insulation
the war didn't ban onshore wind and the
war didn't stall British nuclear energy
the Tory government did that
and the story is the same with the NHS
and care and with all our Public
Services
the workforce of morale crisis has been
an iceberg on the horizon for years
low pay housing Child Care immigration
planning skills investment in technology
time and again it's the same pattern
you saw it yesterday from the prime
minister
commentary without solution
more promises more platitudes no
ambition to take us forward no sense of
what the country needs
13 years of nothing but sticking plaster
politics
it's why every crisis hits Britain
harder than our competitors
the only country of the G7 still poor
than it was before the pandemic
the worst decade for growth in two
centuries
7 million on waiting lists and Rising
that hasn't happened elsewhere
you know
one of the greatest privileges of being
born in Britain certainly for all of my
life
is knowing that if you get ill
if you have a serious accident you'll
get decent health care whatever your
circumstances
not every country has that and the
anxiety it causes is huge
it's why 11 years ago in the Olympic
Stadium a few hundred yards away we put
the NHS on display to the world
it's Who We Are
we can't let sticking plaster politics
destroy it I won't stand for that and
labor won't stand for that